bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france énième report donc de
l'échéance de la fin des négociations
est ce que c'est là le signe que chaque
qu'on joue les prolongations dans une
sorte de stratégie mais restent
finalement ouvert aux discussions pour
trouver un accord alors les négociations
ne vont pas continuer beaucoup parce que
comme vous l'avez dit dans votre
reportage l'échéance et le 31 décembre
de cette année et donc ça arrive très
vite et c'est une échéance qui est légal
puisque le royaume uni au niveau du
parlement a voté pour cette échéance et
ne peut pas y avoir d'extension au delà
du 31 décembre ce qui se passe en fait
je pense que boris johnson ne veut pas
donner l'impression d'être celui qui
claque la porte
mais on voit très bien que le l'accord
que propose l'union européenne est en
tous points inacceptables en fait et
montre c'est finalement la suite logique
de quatre ans et demi de négociations où
l'union européenne n'a jamais voulu
négocier de bonne foi et a agi on
pourrait le dire et c'est pas une
exagération que de dire ça à gibert
allemands comme une secte
puisque l'union européenne ce qu'elle
veut elle ne veut pas obtenir un bon
accord elle veut punir en fait le membre
qui souhaitent reprendre sa liberté
et c'est d'autant plus hallucinant quand
on regarde les chiffres puisque l'union
européenne et c'est pour ça que je parle
de sectes joue contre ses intérêts c'est
l'union européenne qui a un excédent
commercial de 86 milliards d'euros
vis-à-vis du royaume-uni et donc l'union
européenne bénéficiant du commerce avec
le royaume uni c'est elle qui a intérêt
à un accord
et malgré ça en fait elle propose trois
conditions
vous en avez parlé un alignement total
les normes pour le royaume uni une
soumission à la juridiction européenne
et donc à la cour de justice de l'union
européenne et une ouverture totale de
ses eaux territoriales
ces trois conditions en fait elle ne les
impose à aucun autre pays dans le monde
quand elle conclu des accords de
libre-échange l'union européenne a
conclu des accords de libre échange à
travers le monde toutes ces dernières
années les plus marquants était
évidemment le canada avec le set en 2000
16 ou avec le japon le geste à et ces
conditions là elles ne les ont pas
imposer à ces pays et le royaume uni
avait une demande finalement assez
raisonnable qui était de dire nous on
veut un accord comme ce qu'a obtenu le
canada or l'excédent commercial l'union
européenne avec le canada c'est
seulement 10 milliards d'euros et
l'union européenne en fait est prête à
se tirer une balle dans le pied à faire
la politique de la terre brûlée pour
punir le monde qui souhaitent reprendre
sa liberté ça ça a des conséquences
dramatiques pour la france et les
français ont certainement y revenir mais
pour quelle raison alors à ce que boris
johnson jours et ils le jeu de la
poursuite des négociations célébrer
britanniques ne voulaient pas d'accord
il aurait pu quitter l'union européenne
a bien plus rapidement non les
britanniques eux voulaient un accord un
accord de type canada mais il est clair
que le royaume uni n'acceptera pas
l'accord tel que le propose l'union
européenne qui vise uniquement à punir
le royaume uni donc dwayne johnson lui
dit ma porte est encore ouverte
et si vous lui proposez un accord normal
comme vous proposer à tous les autres
pays du monde
on sera prêt à l'accepter en fait je
pense que brian johnson ne se fait
aucune illusion sur la mauvaise foi et
l'aspect secteur de l'union européenne
il ne peut pas apparaître comme celui
qui claquent la porte des négociations
dernier round des discussions et donc à
vous entendre évidemment un politique du
côté du royaume uni notamment
oui très clairement parce que boris
johnson il faut se rappeler de cela il a
été élu sur cette question là le slogan
de campagne de boris johnson
c'était gate bridge sinden faisons le
brésil est donc bon et johnson s'est
très bien en fait que toute sa
crédibilité politique dépend du fait que
ce soit il obtient un accord qui est
normal et in qui ne nuira pas aux
britanniques ou soit il sort sans accord
mais il sait très bien qu'il ne peut pas
plier les britanniques quand ils ont
voté en 2016
ils n'ont pas voté pour un brésil avec
accor ou sans accord ils ont voté pour
reprendre le contrôle et reprendre le
contrôle c'est certainement pas être
soumis aux normes de l'union européenne
ou être soumis à la juridiction de
l'union européenne et donc
ces conditions là tels que l'union
européenne propose cet accord il est
très clair que boris johnson préférera
une sortie sans accord que de se plier à
ces conditions qui encore une fois ne
sont demandés à aucun autre pays au
monde et l'union européenne a une
attitude finalement qui dépassent
l'entendement et c'est très malheureux
pour la france parce que la france a un
excédent de 12 5 milliards avec le
royaume uni
je pense à nos pêcheurs je pense à nos
agriculteurs qui exportent massivement
là bas je pense à nos salariés de
l'aéronautique ou les transports et c
sont eux qui vont pâtir de sa cause une
position de l'union européenne qui digne
d'une secte en fait c'est se tirer une
balle dans le pied pour éviter que les
autres pays en fait prennent exemple sur
le royaume uni ait envie de sortir donc
ça absolument dramatique et l'union
européenne étaient complètement foot
sivola dans un new deal est donc un
synonyme à de droits de douane ou de
quotas ça risque évidemment de bousculer
un peu plus d économies qui sont déjà
fragilisées par les coronavirus avec
aussi des répercussions à attendre sur
les consommateurs
alors concrètement pour le royaume uni
le royaume uni pour à commercer malgré
deux sorties sans accord aux règles de
l'om c est donc on se faut savoir que
les droits de douane extérieur moyen de
l'union européenne sont très faibles
c'est la zone du monde qui se protège le
moins c'est de l'ordre de 2,4 pour cent
et donc le royaume uni même avait une
sorte une sortie sans accord pourra
exporter très facilement sur le
continent en revanche le royaume-uni qui
est libre qui ne dépend tout ne dépend
pas de 26 autres états pour mener une
politique commerciale pour augmenter les
droits de douane
eux ils pourront s'ils le souhaitent
augmenter les droits de douane vis-à-vis
de l'union européenne et le faire très
vite et de manière unilatérale et
indépendante et donc c'est plus
justement l'union européenne qui va en
pâtir je pense que le seul fait dans
fait qui peut permettre que l'union
européenne fléchisse et aille vers un
accord classique c'est que les
industriels allemands mettre la pression
sur angela merkel pour obtenir un accord
parce que l'excédent commercial de
l'allemagne vis-à-vis du royaume-uni
énorme c 32 milliards d'euros et vous
allez avoir tous les constructeurs de
voitures et autres qui vont aller voir
angela merkel parce qu'ils vont avoir
de perdre le marché britannique ou du
moins d'être remplacés par des véhicules
qui viennent d'autres pays donc je pense
que la seule perspective d'accord c'est
celui ci c'est l'allemagne qui mettra la
pression sur l'union européenne pour
préserver son excédent commercial
extérieur parce que l'allemagne
on le voit au niveau de l'union
européenne essaye de défendre ses
intérêts nationaux alors que emmanuel
macron c'est tout l'inversé celui qui
est le plus dur
quant aux négociations de l'union
européenne alors que la france a intérêt
à un accord dont on l'a déjà vu avec le
budget de l'union européenne ou avec le
plan de relance de l'union européenne
emmanuel macron au nom de au nom de
l'union européenne sacrifiera toujours
la france et les français
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
charles-henri gallois président de
génération frac site